[Music]  trevor start your engine  Channing Tatum has a need for speed the  fact that these guys goes fast if they  do it like around this track its science  and like the most crazy speeds that I've  ever experienced on Sunday the actor  made his first public appearance since  splitting from wife Jenna Dewan he  headed south to Alabama where he was the  grand marshal of Indy cars Honda Indy  Grand Prix no wedding ring in sight but  he totally looked the part suited up  ready to race and I witnessed lzt that  Channing seemed excited and happy to be  there the weather wasn't ideal but it  didn't stop him from having the time of  his life  there's no you can do that without the  brakes on to be as wet as it is and it  just sticks completely Channing spent  the day mingling with fans and even  posed for photos with racecar driver  and former bachelor re lyin deck jr.  [Music]  [Applause]